est ce que ça vous arrive de rentrer
chez vous les mains vides
jamais depuis 35 ans de prison et pas qu
allez vous songez que jamais vous ne
vous promenez les bras ballants et que
vous ne reculer devant aucune charge 5 6
kg
5000 m
tous les jours trois quarts s'apprêtant
à 6 mais faut il pas de solution non il
n'y a pas d'autre solution que vous
limitiez combien de kilos mais manche
est acquis en paix si c'est bien ou la
mort damas et à l'amour y est siki
longue de 6,7 kg bat dans la clientèle
c'est assez spécial vous avez les gens
qui prendront facilement le métro et un
escabeau meadow que tu prends un taxi à
la station est un petit paquet de
mouchoirs il remarqué une chose l'homme
les mains vides et bien désemparés
[Musique]
mon mac et ça nous arrive verger
parfaitement ça dépasse la taille normal
qu'on va mettre dans un format voyageurs
est-ce que c'est qu'il ya des petits
plus arrivé
monsieur qu'est ce que vous transportez
là je pense marc débrouille au transport
de ces barrymore équipe
les williams ça peut se combiner un
arbre comme ça chez pas ça
gbagbo méfiez vous aussi de certains
porteurs de pékin
[Musique]
c'est un symbole boxe thaï boxe ah oui
j'allais me suis servi à bon prix et
vous promener souvent avec comme son
mari c'est pour rendre la monnaie aux
clients
qu'est-ce que vous transportez visant
monsieur et/ou d'où venez vous je sors
de l'atelier je rentre au magasin géré
pour combien une dizaine de millions
vous n'êtes pas accompagnée ont mis 6 g
brillé avec moi pas de policiers non ben
on demandait compact et démons papier
avec des poignées surtout lors pas de
dire que des gens aiment bien les gros
producteurs des gens aiment bien les
contacts et pourquoi dès l'enfance
l'habitude des paquets insolites des
prises
[Musique]
m